I love close-ups in IMAX because the
expressions of the actors and the the
nuance just comes out better and I'm
accident
Joaquin and I spent a ton of time
together just talking about Arthur and
Joker and where the laughs comes from
and what Arthur looks like and how
Arthur walks and talks and obviously
things you talked about with actors in
general but with Joaquin it always seems
to go a little bit deeper I've really
never met an actor like Joaquin he made
the process uniquely thrilling
[Music]
you're not immune sitting at the desk
you're in it and you feel the character
and you feel the emotion and you feel
what he's doing I used to think that my
life was a tragedy but now I realize
it's a comedy as the dialog mixer
there's a lot that I will do from mixing
standpoint to push some of the intimacy
moments with him and things where I can
actually make it feel like you are
closer to him maybe closer to him than
you want to be at times but I love the
way that Gotham looks in this movie the
sirens sound different they don't sound
like New York sirens and that was
another tall order that Todd wanted we
weren't supposed to make Hill Street
Blues quote/unquote we were supposed to
make Gotham the character of Arthur is a
slow burn turning into Joker so part of
the magic of Joaquin is that that
ability to kind of tweak the performance
so that transformation happened so
slowly do we had to sonically take the
ride with Arthur from where you saw him
to where he ends up playing with that
was a lot of fun but it's a very
delicate tricky thing as he transforms
the lighting gets a bit darker camera
gets a bit lower he becomes a bit more
grand I've been fortunate enough to make
six movies with Todd on this movie more
than any we've done before we would just
constantly remind ourselves there's a no
compromise here
this has to be the best thing we've ever
done you know pressure makes diamonds
it is unlike any other DC movie you have
ever seen I think that a lot of people
are gonna be surprised by Joker you're
gonna walk away questioning some things
it's a good ride that's for sure
seeing it in IMAX are just gonna
heighten that experience it's just an
experience you can't get anywhere else
you
you